my name is paula i work at ziprecruiter
and i am here to talk to you today about
the very sexy topic of data governance
and all of you got up at 10 a.m for that
so whoo
um it's
one of those subjects that like it
sounds very dry it almost curdles in
your mouth as you're saying it but it's
kind of the most important thing that
you can do for yourselves if you have a
messy data stock
so
i'll start off a little bit talking
about zip recruiter problems we're
facing and then what we have done that's
tried to get our house in order
i can't tell you that i have all of the
solutions but i can at least give you a
practical what's working so far
um
so
ziprecruiter um
you've probably heard of us if you
listen to at least one podcast we do a
lot of ads on that uh that particular
media forum
but our mission overall is to connect uh
people to their next great opportunity
um
counterpoint of that we are a
marketplace we're also connecting
employers to their uh next great
employee that's who pays us in the end
but uh this is something we we take
really seriously um
i worked at core previously where we
were a marketplace of knowledge we were
sharing questions and answers
knowledge sharing is incredibly
important but if you're thinking about
yourself as a person operating in this
world
where you work what you do for a living
it's it matters
it matters for your day-to-day happiness
it matters for your economic power in
the world
it matters for the impact that you're
having on the world too i think a lot of
people in this this room are incredibly
passionate about the work that they do
and they want to make a difference
somewhere
so
basically all of this it really matters
in a substantial way and zip recruiter
our goal is to give everybody the kind
of personal recruiter experience that a
lot of us in this room are luckily lucky
enough to experience in the tech talent
marketplace
so
that's a zip recruiter in a nutshell um
slide with some numbers about how big we
are
hundreds of millions of hundred plus
million users almost three million
employers a lot of people think that we
do a decent enough job
but
it's not always been the company that we
are today
so right now we are an ai driven
marketplace we're a matching platform we
match job seekers and jobs
none of this is very complicated
probably to folks in this room
but
so let me see the the machinery to make
that work we're dealing with
hundreds of millions of rows of data per
year per day we might be pushing a
billion
um we've got about 37 models that are in
production right now they range from
recommender systems to nlp models that
are parsing text from your resume trying
to understand who you are your
qualifications trying to understand what
salary is this job likely going to pay
out
these are all the things that we need to
figure out in order to make this
marketplace work
but if you've been listening to podcasts
for slightly longer
you'll also know that this wasn't our
previous business model
so where we started out was we gained
traction by posting your jobs to many
many job boards we were a spammer we
reduced employer toil
and even before that
the company was something else it was a
screening questions product
so if you ever look at our code base it
is called starter view all over the
place starter view starter restarter
view
and that was the original company name i
believe but it was starting an interview
and all that it was was you could ask a
question and recruiters could disqualify
you basically if you didn't answer it
the right way
so
um
normal company story for a company
that's a decade old um
completely rational from the business
side of things
leads to technical irrationality
um so this is an actual
screenshot of some data lineage i think
this is like a section of redshift and
you can see it's cut off there's more
um this is no joke this is what we are
dealing with day to day
um
i feel like i see all the people taking
pictures i'm gonna just own this like
these are the decisions that at some
point we decided that we had to make as
a business uh to move forward
uh but what we end up with is we are an
ai and ml company
and uh tell me how you do ml with that
right
yeah everybody's shaking their head hell
no
um but the the very like it's not just
that it's not pretty as you all know
it's basic usability things um it's data
that's duplicated in multiple places
when i just joined about a year and a
half ago and i think we had six
different tables in redshift that were
purportedly about applies
and just counting them and having basic
attribution information
they all contradicted each other of
course
there are weird uh basically you do
queries you get weird results back you
don't know why
it's even just hard to figure out what
database you need to go to how do you
find it
and very very quickly this becomes the
constraining resource in product
development you just cannot get access
to the data that you need in order to
make good decisions
so
very very true story here um
when i started at ziprecruiter again
about a year and a half ago
i wanted to get to know know the
business just like look at some basic
facts figure out what areas of the
product were important
i wanted to ask the question of what
percentage of our revenue comes from
search traffic visitors
this is something that like everybody
who wants to make decisions about what
products to build or not should be able
to figure out
i open up periscope uh which
has a lot of complicated problems but
uh one of our main workhorses
and i was just like okay let's start a
query i can find some tables that seem
like they should answer this
took me about 10 minutes to get my first
answer
it was obviously wrong
i pulled in another pm who had been
working in this area for longer
and we worked together for an hour
to try and figure out the right set of
filtering conditions and joins that i
had to do we had to ping other slack
channels
we finally got to an answer in the end
and honestly i can't even remember it
because it was so much pain to get to
but
when you add all that up it was probably
a thousand dollars for me to get that
number in terms of the time cost which
is completely insane and again not how
you can really run a business
so that's basic uh
basic opportunity sizing completely
missing
and more importantly when you're
thinking about ai products and
daniel's team is probably our top
consumer of these
it just wasn't in a good state for that
so
usually you are training a model to
predict some some user behavior you have
an objective function
as of about three years ago we didn't
have a single source of truth for clicks
and just we want to predict are you
going to click on this job are you going
to be interested in it
it was not possible to track a large
number of changes to our data over time
we still have this issue in a couple
pockets but
we we have
like job taxonomies skills taxonomies
all these structured data things that we
can leverage
um to
to put data in places where we we don't
have a lot of a lot of content available
we didn't have any versioning on that we
couldn't track changes to it over time
and an analyst with relatively low
permissions could potentially have
shifted the behavior of the site for a
lot of job seekers and we would have
very little way to know if that happened
again the questions that should take
minutes take hours or days this goes for
any model training you want to be to i
want to be doing two
and there's lower visibility into the
state of the product overall
so again what's the opportunity size but
also i deployed this change is it any
good our a b testing infrastructure was
uh
pretty off base too
um
and
then like once it launches how do we
understand if it made a difference so we
were really in this in this pretty
crippling state as as a company we just
couldn't support our mission
so
uh
i see a couple a couple of uh sniffles
of recognition the life-changing magic
of this the sparking joy uh we decided
to take some inspiration from uh marine
condo who is a celebrity decluttering
expert and that is how we have themed a
lot of our project names around this um
but we asked the question like what
about data infrastructure that is
pleasant to work with what about
something where you can just ask a
question get an answer
so this is uh like all basic stuff that
everybody here knows is going to be
important we want to be able to validate
easily we want to be able to reproduce
models
again this is something that's very
common for companies that started doing
ml several years ago
just no we had didn't have any way to
track model promenades for a lot of
things some of these are ml tools
questions
but at the base of it the very entry
level of maslow's hierarchy of data is
data governance
so
this is i hope folks can read this but
i know that the text is a little small
here but
data coverance you can roughly think of
as the set of processes control
structures
that
are going to allow your data to suit
your business needs a lot of times it
it's also covering security and
compliance and things like this but just
basically is this data doing what you
need to do
and at the bottom layer of this
is where you're firefighting
you are in a situation where things are
poorly controlled you're in a highly
reactive state whenever problems come up
and they come up very often
as you move upward you're expanding the
scope of areas where you have control so
projects
organizations
entire company
and you're changing from a reactive
state to like a manageable state and
then a proactive state
so those are the the basic axes that you
have to work along
and now
um i'll tell you
six rules i know it's a cliffhanger
the rest of this talk is going to be
very organizational and
very just how do you make this work in a
company to say first off
this is the technical conference but
data governance by and large is not a
technical problem or not a technically
complex problem is a people problem and
we found that that's how we really
needed to approach it
so the takeaways i'm going to give you
one
making data an unambiguous priority
having clear alignment on that
two
treat data products like the real
products that they are
three
set clear standards
on what you expect the world to look
like
four
educate on all levels and really i mean
absolutely everyone from intern to ceo
five deliver value early
another
core pm thing but looks a little bit
different for some data products
and six is commit to trust
so
let's dive on in
one is making data an unambiguous
priority um i think that we were very
fortunate at ziprecruiter that
we
did recognize at the core of our
business that this was a shift in how we
were running things and that we had to
get in shape we were blessed with that
to start
the journey here started maybe three or
four years ago i'd say
but with some realization that we're
lacking visibility into these very core
things
we started out with some basic projects
to get
core actions into a good state but then
what we really did was we encoded this
in our organizational structure you've
maybe heard it said people are policy in
a government setting in terms of who
gets appointed to different things in
whatever administration
but it's incredibly true and you can
tell a lot about a company by where
who is in what role and how many people
are there headcount is not everything
but it says a lot about where you're
putting
one of your most expensive resources
which is your people
so about a quarter of all product and
engineering it's a recruiter
is focused on data and i don't even mean
model training i don't even mean use of
data i mean
data care and keeping and basic
stewardship
this seems like a lot
it is we think it's worth it
um and
very frankly there is plenty of work for
us to do too
so
i mentioned that at the start of
at the start of this data journey a lot
of the work was around
how do we get these logging this core
action logging into a good state this
was like our very very basic need that
we knew that we needed visibility into
we started out there we proved out the
value
and since then have shift towards a more
balanced portfolio of projects so we
have uh some things that are in major
data centralization efforts that are
doing things like removing the six
different applied tables and replacing
them with one
which is a project that has taken us
honestly about a year
but
so there are projects like that that are
very bread and butter data
centralization and getting the data into
the right shape there are a bunch of
smaller things that are accommodating
work that is required for other project
teams that are going to pay off in the
immediate term
and then we've fortunately been in the
position that over the
in we're starting to take a long-term
view too
where we can say what do we want our
data strategy to be and what bets are we
making on what we need to get visibility
into
um so that's the kind of thing that you
can expect when you actually are
investing people and giving them
stability in the projects that are in
the the product area that they're
specializing in
for us one of the biggest projects that
is is coming out of this is
right now we're a jobs marketplace but
mostly we're looking at the numbers i
mentioned before clicks and applies
if you think about important outcomes
for a jobs marketplace you'll probably
notice a pretty significant omission in
that list
uh has any anyone spotted it
exactly
uh people went into a black hole and we
were not actually able to tell were they
hired or not after they applied
so that ultimate yardstick of are we
doing a good job like we could tell if
customers came back to us but we
couldn't tell like did this work out or
not
and now we've undertaken a massive
effort to actually get that data and get
visibility into are we being a
successful platform or not
so that's a big part of it put the
people where you need them to be
the next is treating data project
products like real products
again joins up recruiter fairly recently
before this i was at quora where we had
this notion of product teams and a
notion of technical teams uh technical
teams were led by engineers we didn't
really worry about them product teams
were run by product people they dealt
with consumers and all the fun stuff um
honestly i was interviewing i
loved all the people i was meeting i was
like this sounds like a really fun role
but in the back of my head there's like
a why the hell do you have pms here like
don't don't the engineers know what
they're doing
um
and anyone who's a pm in this room knows
like that's not what you're there for
hopefully all engineers know that too
but it wasn't actually obvious to me at
the beginning
and
some of what's happened here is just
that the complexity of the problem has
necessitated this new specialization
within product and that's really how how
we're treating it
so
again
it is a specific set of skills it is a
specific set of core competencies that
we work on developing and our people in
the product area
data sets we treat as products with
customers every new one that we're
putting out has a requirements list that
includes different apis
that need to be satisfied whether the
requirements for the data freshness all
of these different properties that we
need to put together
by the same token these products have
customers but as good pms we also strive
to give you what you need and not
exactly what you ask for
i think a lot of our data landscape
right now has developed from people
getting the what they're asking for
honestly
so that is people making periscope
dashes that fulfill a certain purpose
but not thinking about the long-term
effects of like do we have a stable
ecosystem of dashboards what's the
difference between something that's a
disposable analysis or not like it was
just kind of like let it happen
and then that's kind of what resulted in
our redshift and periscope landscape
especially
so as i mentioned before we define the
strategy for data collection and use we
have a long-term vision we set kpis just
like any other product team
and we develop specialized specialized
guides and templates that get off to a
good start
we give ourselves good maintenance on or
a good place to
jump off from in terms of what are the
checklists what are the important things
that you need to do in order to run one
of these projects well
so next up is setting clear standards
again something fairly obvious but if
you want your data to look like a
certain thing you have to define what
that thing is
so as i mentioned we aligned on what are
the requirements that this data needs to
needs to meet what are the use cases it
needs to serve mostly we were talking
about model development
and general analytics use cases
so thinking about most data stores with
those lenses and deciding to is this
going to be the same product that serves
both or is it only serving one or the
other
and very often like my team is doing a
lot of data centralization but very on
often what makes sense for analytics is
not going to make sense for machine
learning so
it's not about everything needs to be in
one place it's just you need to be very
clear about what mode you're operating
in and what can be used for what
so we established a shared shared
vocabulary on this and best practices
support tiers of different data sets
and this is an example of the type of
type of slide that we would have in that
standards process
we had one of our our very senior
engineering leaders literally put
together a 100 slide deck
on all of the terms that you needed to
know if you're building data sets
and all of the expectations for data
sets of different types so this is just
an example of like the the different
trust levels that we have in different
data sets
um it looks like we we had some
formatting changes but
um
you know we we had some clarity of like
okay what is a fact data what's derived
data
should this be cleaned what are the
expectations you should have about how
good this data is
we had a series of presentations i think
over the course of a month or two he
probably spent about 10 hours presenting
this entire set of material to all of
the data engineers in the company
but lest you think that we are
just
going for very very long and boring
presentations about what exactly our
standards are we also do try to have fun
most of our other slide decks have a lot
of gifts in them too
um
so i mean there's a purpose to that it
really helps it be be more memorable
especially to people who are not steeped
in this area
but this is also
an equally representative slide of the
way that we work as a recruiter
next up is education
and i mentioned at the start of this
that this goes all the way from intern
to ceo and those groups obviously have
different needs
so i've talked a little bit about uh the
the needs of the first two a lot of
those are educating about what are we
trying to build how do we make sure that
this works
we also do a lot of demos and office
hours that are aimed at empowering all
functions to really operate in a
data-aware way
i personally host an office hours like a
peer data workshop session
every week where i just tell people
bring your queries like
we'll figure it out together
and this is something where sql is not a
base requirement for most of our pm
roles although we usually try to hold it
within the the data product
specialization
but it's a way for people to get
comfortable with it get used to asking
questions and get used to the idea that
you may need to ask for help in a lot of
cases too
the side quest on this is that it also
helps people really viscerally
understand how complicated our data is
and help us invest a bit more
but those are kind of the what's going
on at the lower levels
the other important part is that we do
product walkthroughs for executives and
really focus on how do we teach them so
i mentioned that they have good
alignment that this is important that's
fantastic
alignment though is uh it's not a diet
it's a lifestyle change it's something
that you're doing every single day
um
and i
as an example of this
when i first started
uh
had an intro meeting with
the cpo and he was he was trying to be
nice he was saying like i think what
you're doing on this team is really
important work i'm really invested in it
like we might not talk about it as much
as all hand slides as the consumer stuff
but like i really care
um
i was like
great okay a lot to unpack there
um and the conversation that we had from
there was
okay why not
uh
like you say this work is important i
need you to actually show other people
that this is important so what what
tools can i give you
what do you need to be an effective data
storyteller
and a lot of times it's it's kind of a
gap they're maybe not as familiar with
machine learning they know that it's
important they know that they want to
invest in it but they leave a lot of the
details to other people
and we really try to make them
understand we point out the things that
are easy and the things that are hard we
talk about why uh why on god's green
earth it takes an a year to actually
centralize to one apply table
and we're doing this
pretty constantly
so i think that you know once we kind of
pointed pointed that out and really have
the conversation about why are you not
talking about this
it really shifted their their behavior
to
um and
like in one of our most recent updates
about prototalks like experimentation
platform was one of the things that the
cbo said he was most excited about out
of everything else in the deck
and that's coming a very very long way
from where we started
so next up is delivering value early
this is
basic for i think any pm you you're
always thinking about what is your your
mvp
but
it's a little bit easy to get lost
lost in the weeds i think for some of
the data stuff because a lot of it is a
long lead time we found that usually
we're working most effectively when
we're running six months ahead of the
rest of the company's strategy so we're
we're building up the infrastructure and
maybe deliver it when you need it
but the bad case of this uh and the mode
that
was a painful lesson for me
we had this case where a team was like
oh we really need to know this specific
attribute about job seekers like we
think that we can customize so much off
of this we really want this on your
roadmap
we said great we went away for a quarter
we developed a model i came back i was
like this is the best model ever it's
like 90 plus percent precision and
recall like i cannot tell you how rare
it is that we get a model like this
and the roadmap had moved on
they weren't sure how much this really
mattered they weren't sure
how much
impact they would get if they
incorporated it into the flows that they
had originally been thinking of
and honestly we are still shopping
around for a use case for today and if
no one picks it up in the next month
we're going to kill it
and that's really sad to me like it's a
good model it did nothing wrong
but
you know we do have to be practical in
terms in terms of our maintenance costs
but the mode that we are working in now
um you know we just kind of like took
our lumps and our lessons but the mode
that we're working in is really
validating early and often
and for a lot of data projects like
centralization is a little bit hard to
figure out but if you're thinking about
models that you expect to be
incorporating in a lot of different
places
there's often a very hacky way that you
can make sure that you're getting value
so for this particular classifier what
we should have done was like take a
small set of users come up with a
heuristic set up the consumer endpoint
and make sure it it worked make sure
that it did something
and that's the mode that we are
operating in now every
proposed project like needs to have a
use case committed and really signed on
to it
and we need to make sure that we're
going to be in a position to actually
use what we're building
um i don't even need to tell you like
all of the morale problems too for the
engineers who built this poor poor model
that is fantastic but again not what we
need right now
and then the last one
again this is going to be the most most
obvious thing in the world but
committing to trust
and
the statement here the power of data is
objective
obviously
as a pm i'm making choices about what is
the data i look at what's the data i
have in the same way that journalism
journalists are picking what stories do
they cover or not there is some
editorializing in terms of what you show
but after that fact what are the basic
facts of what's happening on your
platform
data is objective that's its whole point
it's supposed to level the playing field
in terms of what's important or not
and if it's not doing that then you kind
of have nothing
so
we have made it a very very strong
principle within the company that all
functions absolutely everybody is really
empowered to push back if they think
that we are doing something that is
detrimental to the trust in the platform
and this literally means they can say no
i don't think we should do this
and any pm in my org i expect to fully
stop work when that happens to resolve
that issue
i mentioned the apply table
centralization issue before
over the course of that project we had a
lot of decisions to make about how did
we attribute an application to a
previous click there are some cases
where
we've got like some messy pixel data
some cases where multiple clicks maybe
could have done it we need to make a
decision
i kind of thought that we had hammered
all of them out
and then an engineer started noticing
something weird he didn't think that he
was quite being heard and he just raised
a red flag
he was like no i don't want to talk
about anything else in this meeting
until we resolve this
and because we had that culture of this
really needs to be trusted that was very
okay to do
so he he wrote a manifesto
um
not quite it was like a three-page
google doc of all the things that he
thought were wrong and like potential
mitigation strategies
it was fantastic it was detailed i told
him like great run with this you know
nicely delegated like yeah track this
down you care about this let's do it
but
in some
some places you
would run into a circumstance where it's
like yeah but we really need to get this
out the door and that absolutely cannot
be your mode of operating in a data
world
um so we we nurtured this we encouraged
it we gave good feedback he got promoted
the next cycle and i know that in
another culture he it would be a
situation where that would have been
something that is very detrimental to
his career
um so i've got a couple couple cases of
that again we have like data spaghetti
so
that kind of conversation actually comes
up a lot very rare to the like very red
flag but we talk about trust very often
and the thing that i am telling all the
engineers on my projects is tell me that
you are proud of this product and that
you are sure that to the best of your
ability this is doing what it's expected
so we really emphasize product quality
again that doesn't mean that absolutely
everywhere you are completely
completely 100 rigorous
it means that you are very clear though
when you are operating in a hacky mode
versus a this is a trusted data set that
you can use for very general purposes
so
that's where we've gotten that's what we
the tools that we've used so far i'm
sure that we're going to learn more
along uh along our journey but at least
what i can tell you now is that we've
actually moved the needle on this so
2019 wasn't there at the time
i'm told it was a really wild situation
and i see a lot of slide deck that
seemed to back that up
and over just the last year and a half
that i've been able to observe there's
been really marked progress in terms of
how well we can quantify this how easy
it is to answer basic questions and the
velocity too that we can collaborate
with machine learning and actually build
on top of this
so
all that to say we're not at the
promised land yet if i'm back here next
year happy to give you an update on
what's going on here um but basically
for any of you that are also struggling
with 10 plus years old infrastructure
there is hope
it's a lot a lot of people work it's a
very steady excellence over time and
consistency type of problem but progress
can be made
so that's my spiel happy to take any
questions you have
[Applause]